good morning Hank it's Wednesday and
today we're going to talk about Robert
Pattinson fiction ality and flava flav
ok briefly Hank since you know nothing
about popular culture there's this guy
named Robert Pattinson and he plays
Edward Cullen in the Twilight movie and
he's beautiful also he has a majestic
puff and he made puffs cool again so
he's kind of my hero but I've been
thinking recently what is it that we
find so beautiful about Robert Pattinson
I mean aside from his top not puffing
excellent cheekbones I think I would
submit to you that while some of Robert
Pattinson x' beauty is just his pure
natural god-given good looks the
majority of his beauty is something that
we have collectively constructed I know
this because recently I was listening to
an interview with Robert Pattinson and I
was like dude shut up
you're ruining it so hey I'm gonna come
back to our pads but for the last couple
weeks nerdfighters have been playing a
lot of 20 Q at 20 Q net which is this
website where you answer 20 questions
about a person and this artificial
intelligence magically thinks of the
person you're thinking of although not
always because recently a nerdfighter
sent us an email saying that they've
been thinking of Holden Caulfield and
20q had guessed flava flav like what
kind of questions did it ask to confuse
flava flav and Holden Caufield are you
male yes do you wear an accessory that
is meant to be cool but actually just
exposes your insecurities yes do you
have any musical talent
doubtful do you have aborted
relationships with women who may or may
not be prostitutes yes actually Hank the
more I think about it Holden Caulfield
and flava flav have a lot in common
right so but anyway there's this website
called 20 Q net and nerdfighters taught
the website about you Hank and after
that a nerdfighter named Paige Harwood
emailed us and she was like you know
what would be cool if nerdfighters made
some one up and then convinced the
artificial intelligence at 20 Q net that
that person was real and Hank as someone
who's read my new book Paper Towns you
know that I'm a little bit obsessed
about how fictional things can become
real so I was very excited about Paige's
idea so a few hundred fighters and I got
together in a blog TD room and we
invented DJ page rail stone and together
we invented an identity and a history
and a career for DJ page real stone
allen created a website karen cat
mash together some photographs so we've
done what she looked like and then we
made a Twitter and a website and
Facebook fan pages and within two days
if you typed page into Google the first
suggestion was page rail stone now a lot
of people have been asking me if page
rail stone is made up and they've asked
whether she's real we did make her up
but that doesn't mean she's not real
because we also made up Rob Pattinson
and in fact in so far as all of our
identities are dependent upon the way
other people imagine us we're all making
each other and ourselves up all the time
now the 20q database is still not
convinced of page rail stones reality
but at this point I certainly wouldn't
put it past the nerdfighters so Hank
that's the point of page rail stone is
to find out how real made-up people can
become and also to remind us that we are
not innocent bystanders in the world of
celebrity in the end Robert Pattinson
has us to thank and blame for his beauty
anybody interested in Page real stone
can find out more about her in the
sidebar and feel free to email original
music fan art album art whatever to
deejay rail stone at gmail.com and then
we'll see over time how real she gets
but Hank she'll never be as real as you
or should I say the set of associations
and constructions that we utilize to
form our image of Hank Ness you'll see
me on Sunday
Bobby Pattinson you may be nothing but a
series of constructions made up by the
people who love you but you're still
real in my heart